so the same way Dolly can turn text into
new art music LM can take a database of
Music That's tagged and turned text into
music so you can be really simple and
generic or you can get really
descriptive with your text so here's
what it made for example for a
meditative song
so that's pretty good but here's
something completely different whistling
a Mozart symphony
so here's something funny about all this
the same way Dolly doesn't actually make
real words when it's synthesizing
pictures it's just kind of jumbled it's
the same thing here with lyrics so it
doesn't really form complete sentences
that make sense so here's what sounds
like when you ask it for a rap slash hip
hop song
[Music]